what he said is he's always complaining
about lack of ammunition so he said that
the the Kremlin or the military in
Russia are keeping Wagner fighting short
of ammunition because they want them to
lose because they want to destroy them
and in the past he's criticized a Shogun
the defense minister in garasimov the
chief of the general staff by name
saying these people I want Wagner to
lose and he always appeals to Putin
directly this time he's actually he said
Putin is an expletive Granddad now he
didn't call him Putin but Putin often
gets called the Grandad so when he's
when he says expletive Granddad I think
we know who he means he might have
overstepped the mark this time because
he's always relied on his personal
friendship with Putin they go back a
long way as friends he was the caterer
to Putin he got the contract for Russian
schools then the Russian military
um he's a you know he's an old criminal
precaution and he set up a grocery firm
in Petersburg in the 1990s and then
casinos and it was Putin who gave him
the license for his casinos that made
him very rich so they are personal and
Putin himself he runs the Kremlin like
sort of medieval Court nobody has an
official job anymore it's all people
relating to him so pragosan I think out
of frustration he's now criticizing
Putin directly because of lack of
ammunition on the back of the front
because he feels that he's Wagner
Fighters have now got to he said we'll
pull out by today by the 10th of May if
you don't give us more ammunition well
that hasn't happened yet but he's
playing politics inside the Kremlin and
khadirov who's the head of the chechens
he said well if you pull out there's a
good air off talking to Putin looking
very nervous as he did it he said if you
pull out my Churchills will go into back
mode we'll take your positions and there
are four different groups in back mode
some of them official some of them vdv
the Airborne some of them the Warlords
and nobody is in charge and so they're
all blaming each other for what has gone
wrong that's the problem yeah it can be
a very confusing picture on that front
what do you understand the situation to
be inside Bachmann yeah back much itself
is still the the the ukrainians are
hanging on to a little sliver of bakmut
a little sliver of The Westerns part of
of the town and they conducted a local
offensive last night and reputedly the
72nd Brigade the Russian 72nd Brigade
took a lot of losses fell back and
Wagner was exposed because of that
Rodney people got killed because of it
but it's all to do with the road the
to504 which is the road that goes down
to Costa anti-nifica that is the way of
Escape for the ukrainians as long as
that road is open they can still Escape
in reality in reality the ukrainians
have all but lost back mode but until
they lose that road they don't have to
admit that they've lost it and that road
is their Lifeline so as long as it stays
open it just about is open just about
then they can still say that they are
fighting in back mode and the Russians
have not yet got the prize whatever it's
going to mean to them of capturing one
place after 10 months
um and just going back to the Wagner
group
as an organization if you can call it
that we know that they're mercenaries
but there could be a bit of a turning
point in terms of the UK a set to Brand
them as a terrorist organization what
what made a difference does that make
yeah not much more than symbolic to be
honest it will take some time to push
through legally but it will it'll close
a loophole it'll prevent pragosan who
tried to sue Elliot Higgins the man who
set up bellingcat which are very very
respectable organization and they tried
to sue him for defamation for saying
something that was absolutely true and
what the Russians do is like the
oligarchs they go in for big expensive
legal cases to try to frighten people
off because of the costs of it it means
that they won't be able to do that they
won't be able to push anything through
London because there'll be a terrorist
organization it won't be able to put any
money through London they won't be able
to work through London and nobody else
will be able to work to them from London
so if it happens then it will close a
loophole and it's symbolic but don't
hold your breath on this one okay
Michael thank you Professor Michael
Clark bear with the latest
on Ukraine